oh boy here comes another fiery hoop
here comes another opportunity to show
what I can do
it's a dance with with the big guns to
dance with the big guns is that a thing
- ility so high fidelity was my big
breakthrough role I got that because
John Cusack was a fan of my band
tenacious d he thought I was funny and I
felt I'd be good in in the role I was
nervous about it because it was a movie
about rock and roll and it was about
people who worked at a record store and
were kind of snobby and and had real
strong opinions on what music was good
and what was bad and I was like I don't
know if I want to do that I have a band
I really am a musician I don't know if I
want to make a movie about people
criticizing music eventually I realized
I'd be an idiot to turn down this role
it's a great character and I took the
plunge and had the time of my life
the director Stephen Frears is one of my
all-time favorites to work with I called
him the Warlock because he had the thick
juicy bushy eyebrows and he looked like
he had magical powers and he was grumpy
and he would often times lay on the
ground and just look at the sky say I'm
too old to be directing this movie but
then he would get up and he'd give me
like the perfect piece of direction and
a lot of that movie was just adrenaline
for me I was just like don't blow it
jack this is your big chance so I came
out of the gate windmilling just acting
as though my life depended on it
so the big finale of the movie there's a
concert and my character whose only
criticized music and musicians the whole
movie is finally up on stage and he has
to actually perform and there was a lot
of talk about what song I was going to
sing and one of the writers DVD
incentives wanted me to sing that Marvin
Gaye
song and I was like why would I do that
song I mean that song is a good song and
everything but I'd rather do like a
bigger more iconic so I'm like let's get
it on
and he's a kind even's diva cent s or
like let's get it on dude that's a big
song alright if you think you can handle
it I think I can handle it and then it
came time to sing it and do the scene
and I did it and the first take I was a
little trepidatious I was a little tip
tone a little bit I was a little
cautious and um it definitely sucked and
I'll never forget Stephen Frears the
director said God and he got angry at
everyone on the site except for me he
didn't say anything to me extra this is
the finale of the film everyone on your
feet aah cheering excitement everyone
Jack great job let's do it again
and I said oh man I know he's yelling at
everyone else but think he meant to be
yelling at me but he didn't yell at me
whatever it was it gave me this crazy
adrenaline goose and I came out in the
second takes wing in and that's the one
they used in the movie
[Music]
[Applause]
shallow house after a high-fidelity I
don't have to like send my headshot and
resume around anymore I start getting
offers one of the big offers I got was
shallow how to work with the legendary
Farrelly Brothers who were coming off a
unprecedented string of successes you
know they had huge comedic blockbuster
movies Dumb and Dumber all that stuff
with Jim Carrey and with Ben Stiller
they had that huge hit Something About
Mary so when they came a-knockin i said
yes
and ya found out that Gwyneth Paltrow
was gonna be playing opposite me so I
was stoked because I was a huge fan of
hers not only as an Academy
award-winning actress but also I knew
that she was funny as hell I saw an SNL
just crushing it and I was like she's a
real character actor she's not just like
a leading lady romantic interest she's
also like a straight-up badass when it
comes to inhabiting different characters
and she really you know got inside that
one literally and figuratively like
emotionally what it was like to be that
person and also she was inside of a suit
that was like three times her size
are you sure that's what you want to do
[Music]
[Applause]
the cuckoo clock was mine that was my
own little spin on it my little
improvisation Jason Alexander's in the
movie as well and he's on the Mount
Rushmore of television comedy because of
Seinfeld one of the great and blustering
buffoons of television history and it
was awesome to get a chance to go
toe-to-toe with a legend it was cool
just hanging with him on the set he had
a lot of cool stories but you know what
was cool about the Farrelly Brothers is
it was a really funny script and a funny
story but it had a lot of them emotional
underpinnings to you know it was about
how we judge people mmm by the way they
look and we don't really go beyond just
their physical appearance and it had
some cool resonance in that way and I
think that's why it stuck around for all
these years people still compliment me
on that movie and I think that's why it
struck a chord Orange County so I did
this movie Orange County which among
other things was the first time I worked
with Jake Kasdan incredible director of
Jumanji the next level in Jumanji
welcome to the jungle and I had such a
blast working on that character he's
kind of a Jeff Spicoli
he's a stoner and he is kind of a big
brother to Colin Hanks character but um
it was a real blast to play because he's
just sort of living life by the seat of
his pants you know
just following his nose and he's kind of
a train wreck of a human being but he's
also kind of lovable and it was a great
character for me
do you want me to call Public Safety do
you want me to get naked and start the
revolution I had a lot of fun with it
and in that movie I got to party with
Colin Hanks was great we had a great
chemistry
what yeah some cops are right on my ass
no listen I've been thinking about it we
are going on Mexico buddy right now I
got to work with Ben Stiller and a rad
scene she named Joe John what is it Joe
John Ames Joe Tom Johnston Johnston Joe
yeah everybody on the in the cast and
Jake were just incredible to work with
I'm very proud of that movie I mean it
was just sort of an amalgamation of all
the stoners that I knew growing up in
Hermosa Beach but no no one in
particular
maybe weirdly closest to myself of all
the characters of Italy School of Rock
so I did Orange County right and Mike
white wrote Orange County and Scott
Rudin produced Orange County and so
Scott hatched this plan to give me the
lead role in in a movie and he was
talking with Mike white about it like
what can we do because Jack's so funny
in Orange County well can we do that
that would really feature him as the
central character and Mike had this idea
he was like I think he should be
teaching kids out of rock and Scott
Rudin's that go write it and Mike just
told me hey I've been hired to write a
script for you and what do you think
about this concept I was like yes do it
go and he wrote this script and I didn't
tell him any I didn't guy give him any
guidance or anything I didn't really
develop it at all I just read his first
draft was dynamite is hilarious Scott
Rudin the producer
said I want you guys to meet this
director Richard Linklater I was like I
love Richard Linklater right I saw his
film slackers which is this incredible
you know bohemian movie about artists
and eccentrics in Austin Texas and I was
like but that's such like an art film I
don't know if he's really the right
director to direct a big you know studio
comedy but then we met him and I was
like oh I get it
and that's kind of the genius of Scott
Rudin knowing who to put together to
make magic happen because Linklater was
taking it seriously and taking it to
another level of like believability he
wanted everything to be rooted in in
reality and to believe that these
characters are real and these kids are
real and that this crazy scenario could
have happened in real life and that's
the combination that made it special
and so he and Mike worked together on
another draft and they worked worked out
the beats and we rehearsed it a lot
richard is is a theater guy at his core
that's his roots and me too so I was
super comfortable with that workshop and
scenes with the kids and and finding new
beats like that scene where we're all
going around the classroom and I'm
assigning people their jobs and their
musical instruments and we basically
write a song in the room and one in one
scene without cutting that was all
workshop through rehearsal you know and
added into the script
do you remember this thing I taught you
a minute ago yes and a lot of the movie
had that rad
like malleable development feel to it
and it's definitely like the movie I'm
most proud of that's the one that really
I felt like all the planets aligned and
when we did the first read-through with
the whole cast it was just that it's
just lightning in a bottle that's the
only time I felt that I was like meant
to do something and now the rest is all
just gravy and I say I can die happy
got my school of rock yeah everyone had
their two cents but I would say that
Linklater had real strong opinions about
certain jams yeah he wanted that that
Zeppelin song really badly and he's the
one that said hey you know I tried to
get the Zeppelin music in Dazed and
Confused a movie that he directed before
School of Rock and they said no so would
you do me a favor and just make a video
plea just beg them to use the immigrant
song that we ended up using the you know
that that Viking and so I did I begged
them on video with a huge audience of
extras in the mood in the movie theater
that we were shooting in and they all
chanted with me Led Zeppelin please
bless us with your love I don't remember
what I said it was ridiculous and off
the top of my head and he sent it over
there to them to England and it worked
they were like oh that's funny that's
funny mate yeah we'll let him use the
song that's not a very good imitation of
Jimmy Page but um and it's a great thing
because it's one of the one of the best
parts of the movie that's all
[Music]
the summer you get an $850
I didn't go for the guy miss aura
I was involved in a lot of the music any
music that I sang that was like original
music I wrote or had a hand in writing
that song is actually a band called
Moony Suzuki and that was the song I was
having real trouble writing I was I was
trying to crack the code and I was like
there's too much pressure it's the big
finale song the end of the movie and I
wrote a bunch of different drafts and
none of it was working and then it was a
Saturday night and I went to see The
Strokes the band that opened was called
the Mooney Suzuki and they were so funny
and hard rockin and I was like god I
wish I could write a song like that that
would be perfect for the end of the
movie and I went backstage after the
show and I said you guys I loved your
set um I'm doing this movie called
school of rock would you want to take a
crack at writing the finale song I got
some lyrics here that Mike White wrote
and they're like yeah I'm gonna take a
look at those I'll give it a crack I'll
give you a text I'll give you a text if
I come up with something I was like all
right good luck and I didn't have high
hopes the next day I get the text with
the rough of the song and just killed it
crushed and I was so excited because I
was like yeah I think I might have cried
a little bit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but that just goes to show like the
stress and like this the last-minute
scrambling that can go into making a
movie because we were already making the
movie at that point we didn't have the
ending song so it's crazy the kind of
turmoil that you can put yourself
through making these kind of movies but
thank God we got it
thank you Mooney Suzuki King Kong so
coming off the School of Rock I was just
like riding high on a cloud I was like
things couldn't be better
I just like had a home run of a movie
that I'm super proud of and everybody
seemed to love it and when my agent was
like what do you want to do now what
kind of movie you want to make that's
like I don't know she's like who do you
want to work with and I was like well I
just saw the Lord of the Rings trilogy
and guy those movies are so good if I
could ever be in a Peter Jackson film
but I know that's never gonna happen and
then like the next day I get a call from
my agent sent dude Peter Jackson wants
you to be in King Kong I was like what
no really you gotta go meet him I was
like well I'm gonna mess it up when I'm
gonna go meet him on my blood I'm gonna
say the wrong thing and I went and met
him and they didn't want me to audition
or anything did it was he and his wife
and their writing partner they just
wanted to show me like an animated sort
of version of the end of the movie when
King Kong is up on top of the Empire
State Building fighting off the the the
airplanes the by wing planes and it was
just a beautiful sequence
I got chills watching it and they said
so do you want to be in our movie and I
was like yes yes do so then we go off to
New Zealand and it's a long shoot we're
there for like six months which is twice
as long as a normal movie because it's
just huge and sprawling and I was in
heaven
loved being in New Zealand Wellington
New Zealand beautiful country going to
work every day was just I didn't want it
to end like when we got to the end of
the shoot I I'm not ashamed to say I
shed a couple man tears because I I just
wanted to live there and and and never
stopped making King Kong's so the huge
scene where I'm fighting off all those
prehistoric insects and disgusting and
flesh-eating bugs usually when you do a
big special effects thing like that they
say very precisely walk three steps and
then swat at this tennis ball and then
look up because then other things coming
but this time Peter Jackson was like
forget all of that just walk into this
set and it looks like a disgusting
prehistoric like losing landscape and
just pretend like there's literally
thousands of man-eating bugs coming at
you from every direction and just go off
just be swatting around and for your
life and we'll just add all the special
effects later as I okay
it was such freedom I didn't have to
worry about blocking I just could let my
imagination run wild and that's
basically what that scene is we're all
just like swatting at monsters in art
from our subconscious mind
it's really fun to shoot an incredible
cardio I'm gonna start a new exercise
class called killing man eating bugs
naturally today so Nacho Libre was an
incredible opportunity to work with
amazing filmmaker Jared Hess I was such
a huge fan of Napoleon Dynamite and I
got the call that he wanted to
collaborate and I said okay meet me at
the top of the parking lot over at the
ArcLight theater so we met there was a
weird place to meet I don't know why I
wanted to meet there there's a nice view
of the city I thought it would be a good
place for an epic power meeting looking
at the view of Los the Los Angelenos
skyline and he told me the idea of this
guy that had two life's one life that
was just for the Lord and this other
secret life that he has to where he just
he loves wrestling
then we would but they they can't
coexist you know a man of the Lord
cannot live a life of you know violence
so he's torn his soul is torn and the
way that he described the world was so
funny and rich
I was worried though it's like dude he's
a Mexican character I don't know if I
should play that character and he told
me that he had a plan for that was that
my father was Swedish and my mother was
Mexican and they they I was born in
Mexico and I grew up there but that's
why I'm a gringo I wouldn't have to you
know to any of the things that would be
considered spicy so we dove in headfirst
and just had a ball and it was such a
beautiful location we filmed all in waka
miss Mexico
[Music]
so me and Hector start off as enemies
and over the course of the film we come
become best friends and also we have
philosophical differences I am a man of
the Lord and I believe in in God and
faith and he's a man of science he only
believes in science but somehow we still
work together to become one of the great
wrestling tag teams of all time
I don't take the rules I do get a lot of
people saying going out of my face John
Shaw then they borrow some sweets that's
another good one and a lot of that is
just imitating Jared Hess the director
has an incredible talent at doing voices
and character work himself and I always
told him to you got to be the star of a
movie you're so funny and he has no
interest in that doesn't want to get up
in front of the camera but it's one of
the things that makes him such a great
director even they say they say you're
never supposed to do it but he gives the
best line ratings and sometimes I would
even say let me hear how you would say
and he would say I would just bust a gut
laughing so hard he made it really easy
I recommend working with Jared if you
want a really hilarious performance and
I really worked my ass off learning how
to wrestle it wasn't without injuries I
at one point sustained a bad gash on my
eye diving out of the ring and I hit my
head on some of those folding chairs and
I had to be rushed to the hospital and
the producer said hey he's an actor
he's got to be able to use his face
let's not just get a search and let's
get the best plastic surgeon in Mexico
over here as soon as possible
and this incredible plastic sir
came to the hospital and she was dressed
in a full ball gown she had come
straight from like a fancy event to
where she was in a ball gown and she did
the surgery on my eye and as you can see
she did incredible work you can barely
see it you can't see it really at all
yeah thank you wherever you are
incredible surgeon Tenacious D in the
Pick of Destiny well you know my whole
career kind of got jumpstart about
Tenacious D because that's how I got
high-fidelity my big breakthrough role
and I always got a special satisfaction
out of doing tenacious T because it was
the it was the one job that I had where
I was the writer director you know
auteur of the project and you got a
special source of pride with that
because you're not just a puppet in
someone else's game even though you know
all movies are a little collaborative
and you get to put your two cents in
Tenacious D was my baby
you know so even while my career was
taking off and I was getting all these
big Hollywood movie roles I always kept
the burner going for Tenacious D and in
between movies working with Kyle on new
material and new songs and we realized
that we were at a crossroads it was time
to take it to the next level
we had already done a TV series a little
limited HBO series we did our big album
and it was time to make Tenacious D the
movie and we worked really hard on on
writing that story and when I like to
answer what should it just be like
another weird adventure of tenacious d
or wouldn't
and we realized no it had to be the
origin story of tenacious ooh where did
we come from and it had to be the true
story of exactly the way it went down
with some extra details to make it more
exciting like we never actually met
Satan at a crossroads but we had to put
that in there to make it give it a
little extra rocket sauce
yeah it was magical we got everyone we
wanted I wanted meat love to play my dad
we wanted Ronnie James Dio to be in
there to be my inspiration
we got Tim Robbins to play the creepy
stranger everybody that we asked said
yes and we made the exact movie we
wanted to make we made a kickass theme
song music video to promote the movie we
went on SNL we did everything he could
do and then the movie came out and
nobody went to see it and we were
devastated but we were still proud of
the movie you know and over the years
it's been like what has it been like 12
years now 13 years people still come up
to us and tell us how much they loved
the movie when we play concerts all
around the world to thousands of people
they all know every word of the songs
from the Pick of Destiny so it really
has sort of built a cult following over
the years just because something doesn't
get you know a hundred percent on Rotten
Tomatoes and zero people go to see your
movie doesn't mean that it has to be the
end of this story if you if you love the
the work that's all it really matters
because they can find an audience
further down the road the holiday
so I had done nacho the Pick of Destiny
King Kong and then I got this offer for
this movie that was a lot different in
tone
it's like softer it was sweeter this is
a romantic comedy but it was really well
written and I was like oh you know what
my mom's gonna love this one and it was
also an opportunity to work with Kate
Blanchet no sorry Kate hold on a second
we're living here and it was also an
opportunity to work with Kate Winslet
the great not to be confused with any
other Kate Winslet and I was like wait a
second this isn't really gonna happen
Kate Winslet's not gonna do a movie with
me she's gonna go for a leonardo de
capital mic blackity yes you was Hey I
got you the best drink in town but I
didn't know if you liked a little dog
whipped cream or a big dollop so I got
both and you can have each one with a
little big dollop great by the way
thanks really great thanks I'm feeling
good I've been working out with Arthur
I'm sure it's an awesome workout I'm
sorry I was trying not to picture it
okay well the workouts not that great I
was the big winner there cuz just
getting to be in a movie with her and
cameras were rolling and I'm looking
across at one of the best actors living
and in her eyes are the reality of the
character and she's just like a pro on
another level so I learned a lot just
from like doing scenes with her and
watching her and how it committed she
was and how real she was I mean that's
not really something you can learn you
can't learn to be charismatic like that
you got to be born with it but just her
level of commitment was infectious and I
felt like I picked up a lot of a lot of
that energy you know
traffic Thunder so Tropic Thunder was a
rad project that dropped in my lap ben
stiller was gonna do this big epic
comedy out in Hawaii
sounded like paradise the cast was
intense
yeah danny mcbride but this is before
eastbound and down so people didn't
really know what an incredible
firecracker of an artist he was yet and
he got Robert Downey jr. but this is
before Ironman this is after his like
scandal it was like his career was over
so he was he was on the comeback trail
at that point people didn't know he was
about to explode and be the biggest
superhero movie star in the world
there's a lot of people that were like
getting ready to pop in that movie you
could feel it on the set there was a lot
of electric energy the movie itself was
groundbreaking in that it was super dark
and funny and real like cinematography
was Academy award-winning level there's
a lot of things you had not seen before
in a comedy and it was hard comedies are
supposed to be super easy but dude the
locations were remote you say oh you're
filming in Hawaii oh that must be really
chill that's probably paradise but every
day dude we had to get in a weird Jeep
and drive over Hill and Dale like really
intense landscapes mud spraying God for
like an hour and a half to two hours
every morning you get out there and then
get into your costume and makeup and and
and work and we were like slogging
screaming bloody murder hiking up
mountains and doing really intense
scenes but in the end of it at the end
of the day it was worth it because it
was funny as hell and really original
but the scenes that I remember the most
are the ones where I felt like I was
actually gonna die
I was on the back of a gigantic water
buffalo
Charlie Chester he's a fashion chic
c'est l'heure de chez Dede
it was carrying me around a mountain
pass we were on like our 13th take and I
didn't blame the water buffalo cuz I'm
I'm heavy and it didn't want me on its
back and it just started buck and I was
like I want you off my back right now
and it started bucking bronco nothing oh
and they were like God God looks like I
can't stop him he's blue I went flying
flip ass over teakettle somehow
miraculously landed between two big
boulders little wind knocked out of me
but no lacerations no injury miracle I
should have died and then uh been still
it is everyone okay we take it from the
top guys I was like you we're not taking
it from the top Buffalo and I just
walked off the set I thought justifiably
I didn't think I was a being a diva at
all and then been realized
dude I realized I didn't know that you
almost died I didn't know what happened
I didn't see it you weren't even on
camera I was like it wasn't even on
camera because when something like that
happens you want to know that at least
you got some rad footage know if it went
off the road and the cameraman was like
no this shots no it's good over there I
keep the camera here cinematographers
never one of their showed no anyway
sore subject turns out though that water
buffalo was pregnant that's why it was
freaking out no one knew cuz she wasn't
showing and the baby's fun and guess
what they named it jet black
if he ever made a big ass water buffalo
named Jack Black Elmo was
Jumanji welcome to the jungle yeah I
love the true munch of the original
Jumanji with Robin Williams Kirsten
Dunst and the rest they're on Jumanji IL
incredible movie incredible performance
by Robin Williams because he thrived in
characters and scenarios that were
extreme because he's such an extreme
like 100 miles a minute brain of a
comedian it's like he's from another
planet so he's playing more from work it
fits his personality because it's like
what are you how do you do this
and in Jumanji that movie he's this guy
coming out of the game he's been in the
jungle for 20 years barely surviving and
he's insane and it works because that's
like right in his Lane because he's got
some insanity to him you know that's
what makes him so exciting as a
performer and that's why you mangy the
first one kicks so much ass is because
he got Robin Williams at the peak of his
powers in the perfect role for him you
know so we get an opportunity to revisit
Jumanji it's a big title big shoes to
fill but it's a great take the script is
is electric and what's really the best
thing about it is reading it knowing
that you've got Dwayne the rock Johnson
and Kevin Hart in those roles it was
like those guys are gonna be hilarious I
could just see it I heard their voices
while I'm reading it you're telling me
that you're Spencer I am Spencer I'm yep
that's Benson and they're offering me
the role to be the most popular girl in
school I was like I know how to be the
hot chick from high school I know for
some reason I know how to do it Hey
oh my god you guys there's like
literally a penis attached to my body
right now Martha come look at my penis
and it was just like I hope I get this
part I mean I know I've been offered the
part but I feels too good to be true
like the last minute I'm but I I got it
I kept it and and we made it and just as
I had anticipated
grand slam home run felt good
feels good to connect I don't know I
mean it's just you know and like it
comes natural the fact that I'm not
instagramming this right now is insane
here's the thing about Jumanji though
it's thinking about Jumanji welcome to
the jungle it was something that I
realized that we were bringing to the
table because the first Jumanji it's
this little kid plays Jumanji the board
game and gets sucked into the game you
don't see him cut to 20 years later he
comes out of the game and he's like the
jungle I've been in the jungle but you
never see what he saw for those 20 years
but in our movie you're going into the
game you're going into the jungle I
think we got like sucked into the game
and I was pushing early on I hate to
toot my own horn but I basically named
the movie because I was like you guys
that's the difference this movie is
we're in the jungle it should be called
Jumanji welcome to the jungle and one of
the marketing dudes were saying you know
there anyway now I feel I feel dirty for
having taking credit for the naming of
the movie but it's true Jumanji the next
level
Jumanji the next level is all about the
new elements Danny DeVito Danny Glover
Kevin and Dwayne playing those new old
characters is so perfect and it really
is my favorite part of the movie are
these new elements because it kicks so
much ass and Dwayne and Kevin are
perfectly suited to those roles because
they are bickering old farts you know
what I mean they fight each other all
the time but they love each other but
they hate each other but they love each
other and it's perfect
and I think that's what Jake and the
writers were thinking they were like how
can we capitalize on this insane
relationship that they
have and how could we use that and
harness it and yeah he's bickering old
dudes that have this love for each other
and of course you know we got Aquafina
in there and she's a dynamo she's
incredibly funny talented character
actress those were the things I was most
excited about the the the trio of new
rocket sauce my part I got to play a new
character and I was scared about it you
know I was like this is this is gonna be
a real challenge I don't know if I can
pull it off and you know I had the same
fears and concerns with nacho libre has
like I don't know if I should play this
part there's if there's a spice in there
if I get it wrong but I felt really good
about my performance I felt like I
really found the voice and the character
I was really proud at the end of the day
what I was able to come up with I'm
excited for people to see
[Music]